[Música]
muy bien qué tal
sobre un público dejar de hacer una
pregunta habéis oído hablar alguna vez
del teorema de moore el teorema del mono
infinito y ese tema que dice que si
juntas a infinitos monos aporreando
infinitas máquinas de escribir al final
en un tiempo suficientemente largo por
probabilidad por azar al menos uno de
los monos terminará escribiendo el
quijote
bueno pues esta idea sesionaba al
khalifa diet y abdulá así que como buen
califa hizo tres monos de todo el
planeta y los encerró con máquinas de
escribir en una torre durante años
al llegar el momento de analizar los
resultados y leer lo que los monos
habían escrito
el califa estaba desolado había escrito
el quijote pero ni acercarse ni un
párrafo 25 bien escrito 100 años de
soledad 35 habían escrito las obras
completas de william shakespeare unos
cuantos habían tirado por la poesía un
orangután intelectual casi se termina el
sol o el ulises el resto a lo fácil 50
sobres de grade y a formarse
el califa entró en depresión mandó matar
a todos los monos encerró en la torre y
dio por fracasado el experimento con
califa no está acostumbrado a no
encontrar lo que espera encontrar
pero esto es un cuento de césar
mallorquí que leía anoche en el hotel
pero es que los de tc x muy pesados me
han dicho tío que es el primero cuenta
algo que engancha el público que lo meta
con un pañuelo
y en realidad en hablaros de robert
wilson y arno penzias wilson y ciencias
eran dos físicos que allá por los años
sesenta trabajaban en los laboratorios
bell
en concreto trabajaban con una antena de
radio medio en desuso identificando
fuentes de radio en tierra y
astronómicas lo curioso es que pensé si
wilson independientemente de la medida
que tomaran siempre obtenían además un
ruido de fondo y ese ruido de fondo era
siempre el mismo independientemente
donde apuntará la antena o se observaban
de día y de noche parecía proceder de
todas partes eran físicos o los tipos
listos dijeron esto son ruido
instrumental estos de la antena la
limpiaron la calibra lo la desmontaron
la volvieron a montar pero nada el
puñetero ruido ahí seguía y es que ese
ruido no era de origen terrestre ese
ruido era la radiación emitida por el
universo cuando éste apenas tenía
trescientos mil años de edad es una
radiación que permea todo el cosmos de
hecho se llama así fondo cósmico de
microondas o radiación cósmica de fondo
y lo increíble es que a 60 kilómetros de
allí y de manera independiente
acaban de determinar que de existir esa
radiación sería la prueba irrefutable de
la teoría del big band francés y wilson
habían descubierto algo que no buscaban
algo que no sabían lo que el hallazgo
que al principio ni tan siquiera sabían
interpretar y le dieron un premio nobel
por ello no me digas que se nos podrá
levantar un día de tu cama te vas a
trabajar a hacerse un descubrimiento
fortuito y te dan un nobel
esto vale si es tío se vestían que el
descubrimiento no sea fortuito sea
aposta lo más seguro es que no te lo den
pero esto por lo cuento en otro momento
vale no es que
los recubrimientos fortuitos forman
parte de nuestro día a día y no me
refiero a aparcar en el centro de málaga
eso no es un delito eso es un
descubrimiento milagroso de toda la
categoría fuera de esta charla vale no
no no no me refiero a inventos que han
cambiado nuestra vida y que en su origen
tenían un componente de suerte de potra
de chiripa el microondas el velcro el
teflón los post-it los rayos xy cosas
que han cambiado
ya sé lo que estás pensando si te has
pasado tío los rayos-x vales pero los
pósitos tampoco han cambiado nuestra
vida
años 90 los laboratorios pzifer están
haciendo un ensayo clínico con el
sildenafil es un componente que parece
que es muy bueno dilatando los vasos
sanguíneos del corazón
puede ser una fantástica base para un
futuro componente de un futuro
medicamento contra cardiopatías pero los
ensayos no terminan ir bien del todo los
pacientes no mejoran y las enfermeras
empiezan a notar un comportamiento
extraño en los pacientes varones cuando
van a visitarnos a sus habitaciones los
pacientes llevan estas batas que ya
sabéis se nota todo y siempre las
reciben boca abajo en la camilla muy
avergonzados y además dice
y es que el sildenafil efectivamente era
muy bueno dilatando los vasos sanguíneos
pero no los del órgano esperado
de otro órgano predominantemente
masculino 20 años después más de 60
millones de hombres han tomado alguna
vez en su vida el resultado de ese
ensayo fallido la viagra y no me diga
que eso es tierno les cambia la vida en
ese momento
ahora que sabéis esto otra porque tío
de hecho las ciencias pueden tener
descubrimientos fortuitos incluso en los
momentos más insospechados en la segunda
guerra mundial los americanos tenían un
barco de lyon harvey
anclado en el puerto de bari
ese barco lo unen los nazis y se
descubre que secretamente guardaban 100
toneladas de gas mostaza cuando el casco
estafa sabes que estaba prohibido desde
los 3 males de la primera guerra mundial
cuando los médicos americanos van a
analizar a los supervivientes del
hundimiento descubren que la exposición
al gas mostaza ha reducido drásticamente
sus glóbulos blancos en sangre esto les
lleva a pensar que quizás una exposición
controlada en pequeñas dosis el
componente principal del gas mostaza
puede también reducir los glóbulos
blancos anómalos de los pacientes de
leucemia o de linfoma en los restos de
ese barco hundido acaba de nacer la
quimioterapia y de nuevo porque unos
investigadores iban buscando una cosa y
encontraron otra
la suerte la chiripa la potra o la
serendipia como se le dice en este
contexto forma parte de la ciencia de la
pasada del presente y del futuro
estoy pensando que la ciencia el noble
arte de la reflexión de la deducción de
la hipótesis y de la comprobación a la
resulta que se debe a la suerte sea que
un investigador cuando hace un
descubrimiento lo dice el ureca dice o
año que por otra fecha que se limpia
1903 el año 1990 1903 el químico francés
el bar benedictus está trabajando en su
laboratorio de repente para golpea un
mal tras el matraz cae al suelo y se
rompe pero cuidado los cristales no
saltan mantiene su forma de cristal
entonces benedictus enuncia una pregunta
que suele ser clave en este tipo de
situaciones su trayecto pero francés era
falso
benedicto recuerda que ha estado
preparando en ese mal trance una
solución de nitrato de celulosa el
directo de celulosa se ha evaporado pero
ha dejado en su interior una película
'la de lente lo suficientemente fuerte
como para que el cristal se rompa pero
los cristales no salten el maldad
conserva su forma lo increíble es que
benedicto es esa semana había leído un
artículo sobre un incipiente problema
que tenían con los primeros coches que
circulaban por parís recuerdo que
estamos hablando de 1903 y este cuando
hay un accidente los cristales saltan y
podrían herir a los viandantes
un matraz que no se rompen cristales que
saltan en menos de 48 horas benedicto
sostenía el primer prototipo de vidrio
de seguridad que es la base de los que
utilizamos hoy en nuestros coches y en
mogollón de aplicaciones este tío acaba
de encontrar por accidente una solución
a un problema que todavía no existía y
que encima no era de su ámbito o sea es
como cómo inventar los emoticonos antes
que el whatsapp ese tío era un genio
la sentencia es mucho más que chiripa o
suerte no no no
la serendipia es encontrar un tesoro
cuando no tienes mapa para encontrar el
tesoro es como encontrar un baño limpio
en un after a las 5 de la mañana es una
habilidad
la serendipia son la mezcla de suerte y
sagacidad y esto es muy bueno para la
ciencia y muy bueno para nosotros porque
la sagacidad se puede entrenar y la
suerte hasta cierto punto se puede
fomentar muchos autores han estudiado la
serendipia científicamente a lo largo de
la historia dan catalogan diferentes
tipos han visto que tiene influencia
tanto en la ciencia aplicada como en la
ciencia fundamental y lo más importante
han determinado cuáles son las
características comunes al todo
descubrimiento por serendipia algo así
como las características de todo buen
serendipia y son lógicas los entes son
gente muy curiosa con una alta formación
en su campo pero no atenazados por el
dogma imperante flexibles muy atentos a
la observación especialmente aquella que
se sale fuera de lo esperado accidentes
errores etcétera etcétera son
persistentes hasta la cabezonería se dan
tiempo para jugar para manipular para
explorar y sobre todo son personas de
mente abierta saben que un conocimiento
en un campo completamente diferente al
suyo puede ser la clave para resolver un
problema en su especialidad
y al revés
empecé a winston churchill o paolo
coelho depende de la fuente de internet
que busquéis vale
y el hombre a veces tropieza con la
verdad pero normalmente se levanta y
sigue andando como si nada es el indicio
no es el indicio se para mirar donde el
resto solemos pasar de largo
el problema está en que el sistema
científico actual precisamente no está
diseñado para fomentar la serendipia es
un sistema muy enfocado en la ciencia
dirigida a un resultado concreto que
además la mayor de las veces ya sabemos
cuál es de antemano y además como nos
cuesta la pasta hay que hacerlo muy
eficiente con muy poca tolerancia a
fallos está muy burocratizada muy
especializada nada el tiempo para jugar
para manipular para explorar porque
además los investigadores tienen mucha
presión por publicar
hay un chiste que para mí describe
perfectamente lo que es un servicio de
lo que no seguro que lo conocéis todos
es ese chiste en que dos vascos van
buscando setas por el campo y uno le
dice al otro abro paréntesis me va a
salir acento gallego pero es que mis
vascos son la excelencia gallego los que
hayáis vale
[ __ ] patxi mira unos balones de oro y el
otro le dice a ver para qué estamos a
roles o estamos a setas el sistema
científica actual está diseñado para que
todos los artículos de lo que todos
esperábamos que iban a dar dan setas y
no me digáis que en la vida a veces
también vamos a por setas
pero deberíamos pagar a nuestros
investigadores por jugar por explorar
por buscarse en limpias con nuestros
impuestos
año 2004 los investigadores de la
universidad de manchester están
literalmente jugando un viernes por la
tarde con una muestra de grafito y una
cinta adhesiva están jugando a ver quién
logra dejar la capa más fina adherida de
grafito en la cinta adhesiva solo lusos
hay que decirlo también
años 90
un investigador de la universidad de
alicante está explorando el genoma de
una área que habita en las salinas de
santa pola
descubre que ese genoma tiene unas
estructuras muy curiosas que además
también tienen otros microorganismos en
la interpreta como un sistema inmune
adaptativo que tiene ese microorganismo
y que le defiende determinados virus
intenta publicarlo y la respuesta que
recibe es la de siempre mira es que esto
no es muy impactante no es una
aplicación directa
seis años después los rusos reciben el
premio nobel por los experimentos
pioneros con el grafeno un material
monocapa que está llamado a revolucionar
toda nuestra tecnología de los
materiales
años después escondido en esa estructura
encontrada en una área en su genoma
reside la herramienta de edición
genética más potente que tenemos
actualmente y seguramente el futuro
premio nobel christer cash line y todo
por jugar y explorar
es el mito que darwin entre sus
pertenencias tenía el artículo de mendel
sobre las leyes de la herencia el
contenido de ese artículo hubiera hecho
aún más grande la teoría de la evolución
yo soy clave en la revolución de darwin
pero darwin o no lo leyó o no estaba
preparado para esa serendipia quizás
nuestros investigadores tampoco lo estén
quizás la serendipia es un duendecillo
que todos tenemos delante pero que no
somos capaces de ver a no ser que estés
entrenado para
pero el trabajo de investigación asegura
que mis compañeros no están recorriendo
los pasillos buscando
la solicite hay que currárselo
es maravilloso construir un acelerador
de partículas para detectar un bosón y
detectarlo es increíble construir un
interferómetro para detectar ondas
gravitacionales y detectarlas pero si
diseñas un experimento para demostrar
que un mono puede escribir el quijote y
no lo hace
quizás no hayas fracasado quizás tienes
que pisarlo con los ojos de la
serendipia quizás tengas delante un
tesoro mucho más valioso que un rolex de
oro muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]